[Musique]
ok on fore le coffret plainte
les vacances sont à quelques heures de
route dans le bon vieux temps en
arrivant au chalet ou à la plage les
pare brise était souvent mouche très
dense est écrit mais les temps changent
il ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
remarqué que les pare brise sont un peu
plus propre qu'avant dans les dernières
années on a même vu les manchettes très
inquiétant à propos de déclencher les
insectes à quel point on devrait
s'inquiéter
est-ce que les insectes sont réellement
en train de disparaître
oui et non et des normandes et des
insectes
yang ici on compte deux millions et demi
de spécimens y plus de 20000 spécifique
des études qui tendent à démontrer que
les insectes certains groupes d'insectes
à travers le monde décline pratiquement
il y en a d'autres qui me démontre sa
dégaine plaident pour d'autres groupes
il ya des études qui prouvent que
finalement ne pas vraiment d donc on se
rend compte que c'est assez difficile
d'avoir l'heure juste parce que en fait
c'est difficile d'identifier des excès
on doit les regarder sur le binoculaire
dans le monde en fait on a découvert
plus d'un million d'espèces vexé donc
c'est plus que les oiseaux les
champignons les poissons et tout le
monde animal pour confondues
pour chaque vous avez ou 2 milliards
d'insectes qui vous est accessible en
faisant 7 milliards de fois 2 milliards
de ça vous donne une idée de grandeur
on n'est pas sur une planète du mec ok
donc on peut pas vraiment dire que les
insectes en général 10 passes
fqu mais pour certains groupes il ya des
situations préoccupantes mais ni si
certaines espèces sont menacées
ils ont complètement disparu une espèce
qui va diminuer très rapidement souvent
une autre espèce qui va prendre la place
de cette espèce locative et donc c'est
très flexible et plastiques ce qu'on va
voir dans les années qui vont venir
c'est l'exacte semble âge des espèces
qui vont devenir de plus en plus
homogène on veut retrouver les mains
espèce très abondante dans plusieurs
endroits dans une région spécifique de
glock
si la biodiversité des insectes
s'effrite à certains endroits ça peut
être inquiétant parce que les insectes
qui rend des services inestimables aux
écosystèmes
en plus d'être à la base de la chaîne
alimentaire il décompose la matière
liberty lisent les seuls il lutte conte
des insectes qui me louise et bien sûr
ils pollinisent nos cultures
c'est un service qui voudraient entre
235 et 577 milliards de dollars donc
l'on pourrait se demander si ici au
québec les insectes sont aussi en danger
en fait la réponse est aussi oui et non
on a tout le nord du québec criq
pratiquement un touché par l'activité
humaine y les populations d'insectes se
portent iec
par contre dans le sud du québec bon ne
connut la plus grande perte d'habitants
et c'est là qu'on ait connu justement la
plus grande perte les espèces d'insectes
de retour malheureusement plus au québec
donc c'est pas nécessairement vrai que
le pare brise plus propre qu'avant
c'est vrai pour sa peine de région et
intensément urbanisées l'échangé par
l'activité mais il s'agit d'aller dans
nord du québec par exemple pour
retrouver cette joie de voir retirer les
insectes sex-ratio n'apparaît encore
c'est sa mère y avoir des trucs pour
favoriser la biodiversité des insectes
rendez vous sur le compte instagram de
radio canada environnement dans nos
stories à la rue